we're not going to spend a ton of time
on this because we've we've just not
have we don't have that much time left
on today's show it's been so packed but
I do encourage folks to check out the
arrest warrant and the indictment of
George Anthony devold or Santos
including the full list of charges
there's funny stuff in it and there's
interesting stuff in it I'm going to put
up just the first page of the arrest
warrant I don't know why I find this so
damn funny I don't know if it's a
version of satire of some kind or if
it's just totally standard
the arrest warrant lists him as George
Anthony devalder Santos AKA in quotes
George Santos
I couldn't stop laughing when I saw this
because it it may well be that this has
nothing to do with the fact that he has
changed his public name over time
without I'm not saying he legally
changed his name just the way he has
publicly stated who he is videos where
he says I'm Anthony devolder and I run a
pro-trump group I'm George Santos I'm
George Anthony and all these different
things this may just be a completely
standard thing that is no bearing on on
that George Anthony devolder Santos AKA
George Santos as if he's been living a
under a false name for some period of
time absolutely love it but more
importantly
the indictment and the arrest warrant
describe the offenses which include wire
fraud money laundering theft of public
monies and false statements and it lists
the specific laws that that he is
accused of having broken and there are a
number of Articles you can look at which
go into more detail it's actually seven
counts of wire fraud
three counts of money laundering one
count of a theft of public funds and
then two counts of lying to the House of
Representatives on financial forms
that's the that's the false statements
element of this as the article says from
MSN wire fraud is the most serious
charge and carries a penalty up to 20
years in prison and as is often the case
in these situations if we get to a
guilty verdict someday or a plea a judge
would decide do you serve concurrently
or consecutively different charges and
as you might know if you get seven years
on four different charges
consecutively that's 28 years if they're
concurrent it's seven years total so
just all of the different details that
we're going to be following